vamos a hablar ahora de los premios de
Best de la FIFA que veníamos anunciando
desde ayer no hubo sorpresas y Argentina
celebró por todo lo alto y dicho esto
usted se toma el estudio Así es Ángela
Con permiso por favor premio para Lionel
Messi como el mejor jugador Lionel
escalón y fue el mejor entrenador el
dibu Martínez fue el mejor portero y
hasta la afición Argentina terminó
premiada como la mejor del mundo para
hablar de ese tema Bueno ahorita Vamos
hasta ahora con el periodista y
comentarista Deportivo Juan José buscale
quien nos acompaña desde Buenos Aires
Juan José Buenos días gracias por estar
con nosotros se mantiene un poco en
estos premios debes la tradición Por así
decirlo y en un año de mundial lo que se
hizo fue premiar a los campeones en este
caso a la Selección Argentina
Hola Juan muy pero muy buenos días para
todos sí siempre en los años de mundial
se toma la FIFA unos meses extra para
tomar esta decisión es decir
habitualmente el lapso de tiempo de
Premio en premio es de doce meses en
este caso fueron diecisiete Porque a
diferencia de lo que habitualmente
ocurre que se entregan estos premios en
el mes de septiembre octubre esta vez
entregó en los últimos días de febrero
todo porque porque se disputó el mundial
de de Qatar y lógicamente tuvo un
impacto muy importante en el criterio de
quienes eligieron a los mejores del
mundo Probablemente lo que se dice es de
Europa es que se cometió una injusticia
con Real Madrid por ejemplo Por qué
bueno no ha sido
el gran beneficiado de esta de esta
elección recordemos que el resultado de
los ganadores de los premios de Best es
un veinticinco por ciento votos de
hinchas veinticinco por ciento votos de
periodistas veinticinco por ciento votos
de jugadores y 25% votos de entrena por
lo tanto es muy difícil predecir Cuál
será el resultado No claro el Real
Madrid efectivamente parece que eso no
le ha sentado nada bien porque ha sido
todo muy decantado en torno al mundial
Karim Benzema que ganó la Champions Con
este equipo ganó la liga terminó tercero
en la votación de mejor jugador Y vos no
fue el mejor portero y tampoco gustó que
vinicius no haya sido incluido ni
siquiera en el once ideal de esta
selección de jugadores
Sí bueno tranquilamente también podemos
decir desde aquí desde Sudamérica
flamengo tampoco tuvo jugadores
postulados entre los mejores y en el
equipo ideal y fue campeón de la
Libertadores y en todo caso flamenco
jugaba en el continente de los campeones
del mundo por lo tanto Bueno es es un
poco lógico este impacto tan particular
que tiene el mundial en las elecciones
de los premios de Best sucede una vez
cada cuatro años después seguramente el
campeón de la Champions volverá a tener
el lugar que habitualmente se le da
menos en los años de mundial
en las mujeres desplazando al plano de
Quién fue la mejor jugadora repitió la
española Alexia putellas como la mejor
jugadora ella no jugó la Eurocopa con su
selección con España y aún así volvió a
defender Este título esto llevándolo al
otro plano no siento bien en Inglaterra
en donde campeona de la Eurocopa con
Inglaterra terminó tercera en la
votación y en donde Por cierto tampoco
tuvimos en representación Sudamericana
sí es cierto no hubo no hubo
representación Sudamericana ahí sí me
parece que la brecha es muy grande entre
el fútbol femenino en Europa y el de
Sudamérica que está creciendo con lo que
hizo Colombia en la última copa América
con el gran nivel que tiene Brasil pero
todavía nos está faltando para poder
acercarnos un poco más al primer nivel
europeo lo de Alexia Me parece que ella
es la gran embajadora que hoy por hoy
tiene el Fútbol Internacional no aparece
como una imagen de renovación notable es
una futbolista que no solamente es muy
distinguida por sus características
técnicas dentro del terreno de juego
sino que también es una verdadera
de esta escuela futbolística a nivel de
Clubes porque es la estrella del campeón
a nivel de Clubes que es Barcelona a
nivel de Eurocopa a nivel de selecciones
Sin lugar a dudas que Inglaterra hoy por
hoy se lleva en Europa los principales
flashes se va a venir en el fútbol
femenino la finalísima así como el año
pasado tuvimos allá por el mes de mayo
la finalísima entre Argentina Italia en
wembley se va a repetir la finalísima en
wembley entre el campeón de Europa y el
campeón de Sudamérica Pero esta vez
entre Inglaterra y Brasil sin dudas que
será una gran oportunidad para disfrutar
de mejor fútbol mundial primer puesto
para Alexia segundo para Alex Morgan y
tercera fue vete mete en esa votación a
mejor jugadora quizás nos faltó de viña
Juan José búscale como siempre Muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
aquí en France 24
abrazo grande Juan y por supuesto que en
la Argentina este esta distinción en los
premios bebés se lo tomó como una
distinción porque fue una extensión del
Mundial fueron dos meses después la
gente ayer celebró no te digo en las
calles pero sí en las casas Lo que fue
estos premios rotundos para el
seleccionado argentino que siga la
fiesta para Argentina